allez et maintenant les choses sérieuses
le diplôme toutes les antilles
bush et chirac c'est cet homme là tout
sourire et abordable c'est un homme que
vous aimez bon et pour quelles raisons
sa franchise sa gentillesse le sens très
élevé qu'il ya de l'amitié dû respect
des autres et surtout le la chaleur
humaine que je dégage de ces dons il a
aussi gagné le respect et l'estimé
adversaires politiques n'ont pas désarmé
pour l'été
mais je reconnais être un homme
qui est intéressant
profondément aux civilisations
[Musique]
c'est important à la mort d'aimé césaire
en avril 2008 jacques chirac dira de
césaire que c'était un homme de grande
envergure
j'avais pour lui une grande admiration
beaucoup d estime et c'était un homme
qui était capable de vous dire voilà où
devait aller voilà comment vous devez y
aller et quand en 2005 elle il est
touché en plein coeur et meurtri par le
crash de maracaibo jacques chirac
exprime son soutien et sa compassion au
peuple martiniquais
c'est le coeur serré que je m'incline
profondément devant la douleur immense
des familles et des proches
l'homme politique et connaissait les
réalités les difficultés et les souhaits
des martiniquais en politique il a
rencontré des délégations sur la
question de l'évolution institutionnelle
et de l'autonomie c'est la première fois
que nous avons cette initiative nous
sommes donc dans la logique de la
déclaration de basse terre j'ai tout vu
un président à l écoute et j'espère
j'espère que lui même ou à l'occasion de
se prononcer puisque avait que très
bientôt d'oiseaux en d'abord en
guadeloupe et en martinique
hélas ces deux pays ou à l'occasion de
faire de déclaration est potes ils
seront en effet en martinique la même
année pour s'adresser directement à la
population
il parle d'un statut sur mesure la
martinique est en marche vers une
évolution institutionnelle l'élection
présidentielle de 2002 est marquée par
un séisme
le face à face jean marie le pen jacques
chirac conséquence ce dernier et
publicité en martinique à plus de 96 %
pendant sa mandature également une loi
fait polémique et provoqué des réactions
violentes dans l'outre-mer et
singulièrement martinique sur les
bienfaits de la colonisation et
martiniquais exige son retrait
parce qu'on mobilisés sur quelque chose
qui nous semble essentiel et qui devrait
être au coeur même du débat français à
savoir la colonisation en 2007 l'homme
annonce qu'il ne se représentera pas
conformément à la constitution nous
sommes à l'heure des bilans après douze
ans de présidence sera venu pour moi de
vous servir autrement il ya un grand
écart entre les propose la fracture
sociale
et puis la réalité les inégalités se
sont accrues sous jacques chirac l'un
saigne mode se verrait bien c'est le
ministre b au gâchis là qui a supprimé
cet enseignement de ce village oublie
pas cela et puis bon il faut dire que il
à mettre les intérêts du système
colonial dans les colonies de la france
si l'homme politique n'a pas fait
l'unanimité beaucoup reconnaissent une
avancée et pas des moindres l'alignement
des prestations sociales dans
l'outre-mer avec l'hexagone l'égalité
sociale une revendication des
martiniquais depuis 1946